JUAN WILLIAMS, BRIAN KILMEADE.
A CROUTON IS HER LOOFAH.
DANA PERINO.
>> CHAIRMAN KIM AND I SIGNED A
JOINT STATEMENT IN WHICH HE
REAFFIRMED HIS UNWAVERING
COMMITMENT TO COMPLETE
DENUCLEARIZATION OF THE KOREAN
PENINSULA.
>> Greg: THEY INTERRUPTED
"THE BACHELORETTE" FOR THAT?
THIS IS BIG NEWS BUT IT'S ONLY A
START.
A FIRST DATE, IF YOU WILL.
VERIFICATION IS KEY, FOR IN THE
PAST MONTH GRAY HAS BEEN ABOUT
AS TRUSTWORTHY AS SUSHI FROM THE
DRUGSTORE ON A THURSDAY IN THE
SUMMERTIME.
MAYBE THAT PAST IS DEAD.
CHECK OUT THIS MOVIE TRAILER
PRESIDENT TRUMP PRESENTED TO
KIM.
>> DESTINY PICTURES PRESENTS A
STORY OF OPPORTUNITY.
A NEW STORY, A NEW BEGINNING.
ONE OF PEACE.
TWO MEN, TWO LEADERS.
ONE DESTINY.
A STORY ABOUT A SPECIAL MOMENT
IN TIME WHEN A MAN IS PRESENTED
WITH ONE CHANCE THAT MAY NEVER
BE REPEATED.
WHAT WILL HE CHOOSE?
VISION AND LEADERSHIP?
OR NOT?
A NEW WORLD CAN BEGIN TODAY.
ONE OF FRIENDSHIP, RESPECT, AND
GOODWILL.
BE PART OF THAT WORLD WHERE THE
DOORS OF OPPORTUNITY ARE READY
TO BE OPENED.
>> Greg: OKAY.
THAT'S AMAZING.
IT'S GOT TO BE A FIRST.
SHOWING A WORLD LEADER WITH THE
WORLD COULD BE LIKE IF YOU
CHANGE YOUR WAYS.
AS A MOVIE TRAILER, WHO DOES
THIS?
DONALD TRUMP.
WHY?
WHY DID HE SHOW HIM THIS?
>> I SHOWED IT BECAUSE THAT'S
THE FUTURE.
THAT COULD VERY WELL BE THE
FUTURE.
THE OTHER ALTERNATIVE IS JUST
NOT A VERY GOOD ALTERNATIVE.
>> Greg: NOT AT ALL!
IT'S ABOUT TWO OPTIONS.
THE GOLDEN OFF-RAMP OVER THE
CLIFF TO NOWHERE.
IT'S NOT POLITICS.
IT'S PERSUASION.
IT REFRAMES THE FUTURES OF THE
PAST IS THE PAST.
THIS IS IN THINKING OUTSIDE THE
BOX.
IT'S GETTING RID OF THE BOX.
JUMP TO THE SALES PRESENTATION
ON FREEDOM.
NO ONE HAS DONE THAT BEFORE.
WILL KIM DO WHAT'S RIGHT?
>> I THINK HE'S GOING TO DO
THESE THINGS.
I MAY BE WRONG.
I MAY STAND BEFORE YOU IN SIX
MONTHS AND SAY HEY, I WAS WRONG.
I DON'T KNOW THAT I WILL EVER
ADMIT THAT BUT I WILL FIND SOME
KIND OF AN EXCUSE.
>> Greg: THAT IS TRANSPARENCY.
THEY SHOULD FEEL LIKE GOOD NEWS,
BUT IF YOU STILL BELIEVE THE
SUMMIT WAS ITSELF A CONFESSION
BUT THAT IT WON'T.
WITH THAT THINKING, WHY HAVE
DIPLOMACY?
WHAT SHOULD REASSURE YOU?
POMPEO, BOLTON, TRUMP.
THIS ISN'T JOHN KERRY, HILLARY,
OR BEN RHODES, ENTITLED LEMMINGS
OUT FOR LEGACY.
THEY WERE ALL CARRIED.
THE NEW GUYS MOSTLY STICK WHICH
MAKES THE CARE POSSIBLE.
THE ESTABLISHMENT WILL LAST.
THE SAME PEOPLE WHO THOUGHT
TRUMP WAS LEADING US TO WAR ARE
MAD THAT HE IS AVERTING IT.
AS FOR YOU, YOU SHOULD READ THE
NEWS WITH HOPE.
LET'S CHECK BACK IN A YEAR.
WORST CASE WE ARE BACK AT SQUARE
ONE.
THAT'S NO CONFESSION, JUST A
PATH TRIED.
WHAT DID ONE GREAT PHILOSOPHER
SAY?
>> WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO SEE
WHAT HAPPENS.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
WE ARE GOING TO SEE WHAT
HAPPENS.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> Greg: WE WILL SEE WHAT
HAPPENS.
OKAY, KILMEADE, I'M GOING TO YOU
FIRST BECAUSE FRANKLY I FEEL BAD
FOR YOU.
HAS ANYBODY EVER DONE THIS
BEFORE?
PRESENT A VIDEO.
IT'S LIKE A TIME-SHARE
CONDOMINIUM VIDEO THAT A
SALESMAN WILL SHOW YOU TO GET
YOU TO GO ON THE TOUR.
THIS COULD BE THE START OF
SOMETHING NEW.
YOU GO TO OTHER COUNTRIES AND
GO, THIS IS WHAT YOU COULD HAVE.
>> Brian: IT'S GREAT.
I COULD NOT BACK YOUR DECISION
TO COME TO ME FIRST.
I WATCHED IT AND I GOT UP AT
1:30 TWO DO THE SHOW AT 5:00.
HE ALSO SAID THIS ON THE CONDO
EPISODE.
HE SAID WATCHING THE VESSELS,
THE ROCKETS TAKE OFF WHEN THEY
HIT JAPAN.
I AM THINKING TO MYSELF IT'S A
BEAUTIFUL BEACH.
WE COULD PUT CONDOS.
I KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF REASONS
TO SAY IT'S NOT GOING TO WORK
BUT ALL I CAN SAY IS KEEP YOUR
POWDER DRY IF YOU ARE QUICK TO
CRITICIZE THE PRESIDENT BECAUSE
THIS IS JUST STEP NUMBER ONE OF
A BRAND-NEW SERIES OF STAIRS.
BECAUSE NOBODY KNOWS WHERE THIS
IS HEADING, BUT I KNOW FOR SURE
IT'S NOT DONE YET.
THE PRESSURE IS REALLY ON THEM
BECAUSE THIS IS THE BEST CHANCE
THEY WILL EVER HAVE GIVE THEIR
PEOPLE A FUTURE AND GIVE THEIR
MONARCHY, WHATEVER YOU CALL IT,
SOME TYPE OF SECURITY.
IF THEY WANT AN EXAMPLE.
IT IS VIETNAM AND CHINA.
ECONOMIES WHERE WE NEVER WANT TO
LIVE BUT THEY ARE FOUND WAYS TO
PUT MARKET PRINCIPLES IN THERE.
VIETNAM PROBABLY GETS ALONG
BETTER WITH US THAN CHINA AND
RUSSIA THESE DAYS.
I AM ENCOURAGED BY THE CHANCE.
PLENTY OF REASONS TO POKE HOLES
IN IT.
THIS TERM, WHICH I THINK IS NOT
GREAT, COMPETES TO WORK --
COMMITS TO WORK TOWARDS
DENUCLEARIZATION.
IT'S A FIRST STEP.
NEXT WEEK BOLTON AND POMPEO PICK
UP WHERE THIS SUMMIT LEFT OFF.
GAME ON.
>> Greg: WHAT DO YOU THINK,
DANA?
I AM SKEPTICAL BUT I ALSO HAVE A
FEELING OF HOPE.
>> Dana: I THINK THAT'S TRUE.
I KIND OF FEEL THE SAME AS I DID
YESTERDAY.
I HAD SOME UNEASINESS LOOKING AT
THE FLAGS SIDE-BY-SIDE.
NO HE'S AN EQUAL PARTNER.
KIM REALLY DID GET A LOT OF OUT
OF THIS.
ALL THE PROPAGANDA HE CAN USE
BACK HOME.
NOW RUSSIA HAS TO COME TO HIM TO
HAVE A MEETING.
THE CHINESE ARE GOING TO COME TO
HIM TO HAVE A MEETING.
HE NO LONGER HAS TO GO THERE.
THE VIDEO DOES REMIND ME OF THE
IDEA I HAD A LONG TIME AGO THAT
I ASKED GENERAL PETRAEUS ABOUT.
CREATE A VIDEO SHOWING THE
SUICIDE BOMBERS, WHAT COULD
HAPPEN AND HOW RISKY IT COULD BE
HAPPEN AND HOW RISKY IT COULD B
BE.
>> Greg: PRESENT THE
ALTERNATIVE.
>> Dana: I HAD A WOMAN ON
TODAY, A FORMER CIA DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR KOREAN ISSUES.
SHE SAID OVERALL NET PLUS.
I THINK THAT'S PROBABLY WHERE I
WAS YESTERDAY.
HOPEFUL BUT SKEPTICAL.
I THINK THAT PERSONNEL IS POLICY
IN A LOT OF WAYS.
THE FACT THAT BOLTON AND POMPEO
ARE GOING ON THERE IS GOOD.
I WONDER, THE PEOPLE CRITICAL OF
IT, MANY ON THE LEFT, PEOPLE ARE
CRITICAL OF IT BECAUSE THEY'RE
LOOKING AT THIS AND SAYING IT'S
NOT STRONG ENOUGH.
THEY WERE THE SAME ONES WHO
PRAISED PRESIDENT OBAMA FOR
IRAN.
I THINK THE SKIP      SKEPTICISM
I THINK THE SKIP      SKEPTICISI
I THINK THE SKIP      SKEPTICISS
WARRANTED.
>> Greg: PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
GOING TO BE ON HANNITY TONIGHT.
THEY ARE GOING TO TALK ABOUT THE
EARLY RHETORIC DONALD TRUMP
EMPLOYED.
LET'S ROLL THAT TAPE.
>> I THINK WITHOUT THE RHETORIC,
WE DID SANCTIONS AND ALL THE
THINGS YOU WOULD DO BUT I THINK
WITHOUT THE RHETORIC, OTHER
ADMINISTRATIONS, I DON'T WANT TO
GET SPECIFIC ON THAT BUT THEY
HAD UP POLICY OF SALADS.
IF THEY SAID SOMETHING VERY BAD
VERY THREATENING AND HORRIBLE,
JUST DON'T ANSWER.
THAT'S NOT THE ANSWER.
THAT'S NOT WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO.
THE RHETORIC, I HATED TO DO IT.
SOMETIMES I FELT FOOLISH DOING
IT BUT WE HAD NO CHOICE.
>> Greg: WHAT DO YOU THINK,
JUAN?
>> Juan: HE IS CELEBRATING
HIMSELF, RATIONALIZING WHAT HE
DID BEFORE.
>> Greg: HE JUST SAID HE MIGHT
HAVE MADE A MISTAKE.
>> Juan: NO, HE DIDN'T.
>> Greg: HE SAID HE MIGHT'VE
FELT BAD DOING IT.
>> Juan: HE SAID IT WORKED.
TO ME, THIS WHOLE THING COME I
LISTENED TO YOU AND I THINK LOOK
AT THE DEFENDERS OF TRUMP TODAY.
THIS IS LIKE A WET FIRECRACKER.
THIS IS LIKE THE END OF
"THE SOPRANOS" WHERE YOU GO,
WHAT HAPPENED TO MY TV?
WHAT HAPPENED HERE?
>> Greg: THAT WAS A GREAT
SERIES.
>> Brian: DON'T STOP BELIEVING
ON THE JUKEBOX.
>> Juan: THE MAN WHO SET THE
BAR FOR THIS WAS NONE OTHER THAN
OUR TV STAR, DONALD TRUMP.
DONALD TRUMP SAID NO LENGTHY
NEGOTIATIONS LIKE MY
PREDECESSORS.
HE SAID NO CONCESSIONS THAT WILL
STALL AND SIMPLY GIVE THIS
HORRIBLE REGIME MORE TIME TO
PERPETRATE THEIR TERROR.
HE SAID QUITE CLEARLY WE ARE
GOING TO TALK ABOUT HUMAN
RIGHTS, OTTO WARMBIER.
TODAY HE SAYS OTTO WARMBIER
DIDN'T DIE IN VAIN.
BUT YOU DIDN'T BRING IT UP.
>> Greg: YES, HE DID.
IT WAS AMAZING.
REPATRIATION AS WELL.
BE ACCURATE.
>> Juan: I WILL BE ACCURATE.
HERE'S WHAT KIM SAID, WE AGREED
TO LET THE PAST BE THE PAST.
WE ARE MOVING ON.
THAT'S WHAT HE SAID.
LET ME FINISH.
HERE YOU HAVE A SITUATION, YOU
SAY, ARE THESE LEMMINGS?
JOHN KERRY AND OTHERS ARE
LEMMINGS.
IS OTTO WARMBIER ONE OF THE
LEMMINGS?
DID HE JUST GO AWAY, GO OFF THE
EDGE?
>> Greg: THAT MAKES NO SENSE.
I DID NOT SAY THAT.
THAT WAS SO WRONG, JUAN.
I DID NOT CALL WARMBEIR A
LEMMING, YOU MORON.
>> Juan: I GUESS YOU NEVER
READ ABOUT BILL CLINTON AND THE
FRAMEWORK AGREEMENT IN WHICH THE
NORTH KOREANS TOOK CONCESSIONS,
DON'T DELIVER.
HOW ABOUT THE SIX PARTY TALKS.
>> Greg: I STOPPED LISTENING
TO YOU WHEN YOU SAID I CALLED --
ENOUGH, ENOUGH.
YOU ACCUSED ME OF SAYING
SOMETHING I DIDN'T SAY.
>> Juan: SAYING THAT THESE
GUYS ARE LEMMINGS.
>> Brian: THEY DID BRING UP
HUMAN RIGHTS.
KIMBERLY.
>> Kimberly: THANK YOU.
WHAT ARE WE, NORTH KOREA RIGHT
NOW?
I HAVE AN OPINION TOO.
I THINK IT WAS INCREDIBLE TO
WATCH LAST NIGHT.
SO MANY OF US WERE RIVETED, IT'S
AN IMPORTANT MOMENT IN
INTERNATIONAL DISCOURSE AND
DIPLOMACY.
I REALLY HOPE AND PRAY THAT THIS
IS THE FIRST STEP OF MANY
MEETINGS BETWEEN THE
UNITED STATES AND NORTH,
SOUTH KOREA, CHINA, TO BE ABLE
TO WORK TOGETHER.
NUCLEAR SCIENTISTS INVOLVED, TO
BE ABLE TO TRUST BUT VERIFY
WHICH IS REAGAN'S POLICY, AND
REALLY WORK TOWARDS PEACE.
NO ONE BENEFITS FOR MORE.
IN THAT SENSE, I THINK THIS WAS
SOMETHING THAT WAS IMPORTANT, A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
CAN YOU SAY HE TRUSTS THE
ACTIONS OF THAT MAN THAT HAS RUN
A BRUTAL REGIME OF TORTURE AND
BEHAVES HORRIFICALLY TO HIS OWN
PEOPLE?
PERHAPS WE HAVE A SMALL PARK TO
PLAY IN STOPPING THAT, SHEDDING
SOME LIGHT ON IT AND NOT
CONTINUING TO HAVE THEM
ISOLATED.
TO CREATE AND COMMIT THEIR
HORRORS WITHOUT THE REST OF THE
WORLD KNOWING ABOUT IT.
I BELIEVE THE PRESIDENT WHEN HE
IN VAIN.
THAT REALLY DID CAST A VERY
BRIGHT LIGHT ON WHAT WAS GOING
ON IN NORTH KOREA.
I THINK SO PIVOTAL IN TERMS OF
BEING ABLE TO GET POWs, M.I.A.
REMAINS HOME, TO BE ABLE TO
NEGOTIATE FOR THE OTHER HOSTAGES
THAT WERE HELD THERE.
THAT DOES MATTER TO THOSE
FAMILIES AND THOSE THAT HAVE
BEEN GRIEVING AND LOOKING TO
BURY THEIR LOVED ONES.
I SAY LET'S GIVE THIS A CHANCE.
KUDOS TO OUR PRESIDENT FOR BEING
ABLE TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN WHICH
SOME PEOPLE DIDN'T THINK --
>> Juan: WHAT DO WE GET OUT OF
THIS?
WE SAY WE'RE GOING TO STOP OUR
EXERCISES WITH SOUTH KOREA.
WHAT DO WE GET IN RETURN?
WE GET PROMISES, PLEDGES.
OH, MY GOSH.
>> Greg: YOU ARE SUCH A BABY,
JUAN, ABOUT THIS.
>> Juan: WE GOT COMPLETE
DENUCLEARIZATION?
>> Kimberly: WE GOT A PROMISE
TO WORK TOWARDS IT.
IT'S BETTER THAN NOT DOING IT.
>> Juan: YOUR PEOPLE WHO SAY
THE IRAN DEAL STINKS, RIGHT?
THE IRAN DEAL, THE IRANIANS
DIDN'T HAVE NUKES.
WE HAD A DEAL TO STOP THEM FROM
GETTING THEM.
>> Greg: NOW THEY ARE QUICKLY
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
>> Juan: THE NORTH KOREANS
HAVE NUKES.
GIVEN WE ARE SAYING THIS IS
ABOUT NONPROLIFERATION.
>> Greg: USING YOUR OLD,
TRADITIONAL, BAD DIPLOMACY.
>> Juan: LET ME SAY WE ARE
REWARDING --
[ALL SPEAKING]
GETTING NOTHING FOR IT.
>> Brian: I CANNOT BELIEVE
YOU'RE ACTING LIKE DONALD TRUMP
REWARDED BAD BEHAVIOR.
>> Juan: HE DID.
>> Brian: WHAT DID
BILL CLINTON DO?
HE MET WITH HIM AND IS STARTING
A SERIES OF TALKS.
>> Juan: WHY DO YOU THINK
OTHER PRESIDENTS DIDN'T DO IT?
>> Brian: THERE'S A REASON.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE NUCLEAR
WEAPONS, THEY WEREN'T A THREAT.
MULTISTAGE ROCKETS CAN HIT THE